Now Tony and determinism says that the
university has a clock,
I gigantic clock that's wound up at the
beginning of time and it's been ticking
ever since.
According to Newton's laws of motion,
so what you're going to eat 10 years
from now on January first has already
been fixed.
It's already known using Newton's laws
of motion.
Einstein believed in that Einstein was a
determinist.
Does that mean that a murderer is a
horrible mass murderer,
isn't really guilty of his works because
it was already preordained billions of
years ago.
Nine science said,
well,
yeah,
in some sense that's true.
Even mass murderers were predetermined,
but he said they should still be placed
in jail.
Heizer Berta then comes along and
proposes the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle and says,
nonsense.
There's uncertainty.
You don't know where the electron is.
It can be here,
here,
or many places simultaneously.
This of course,
Einstein hated because he said,
God doesn't play dice with the universe.
Well,
Hey,
get used to it.
Einstein was wrong.
God does play dice.
Every time we look at an electron,
it moves.
There's uncertainty with the regardless
of the position of the electrons.
So what does that mean for freewill?
It means in some sense we do have some
kind of free will.
No one can determine your future events
given your past history.
There's always the wildcard.
There's always the possibility of
uncertainty in whatever we do.
So when I look at myself in the mirror,
I say to myself,
what I'm looking at,
it's not really me.
It looks like me,
but it's not really me at all.
It's not meat today.
Now it's me a billionth of a second ago
because it takes a billionth of a second
for light to go for a meeting to the
mirror and back.